[Music]
your
mortal enemy has captured you and hooked
you up
to a bizarre experiment he's extended
your nervous system
with one very long neuron to a target
about 70 meters away at some point
he's going to fire an arrow if you can
then think a thought to the target
before the arrow hits it
he'll let you go so who wins
that race in order to answer we have to
examine the hardware of thought
neurons the human brain has about 86
billion
of these cells they transmit signals
down their axons by way of electrical
impulses
or action potentials one neuron can then
pass that signal to the next
at a synapse by way of chemical
neurotransmitters
the signal is received by the next
neuron's dendrites
propagated down its axon and passed
further along
so the key factors that determine how
quickly you think
include how long it takes to generate an
initial action potential
propagate it down the length of the axon
and transport it through the synapse
we must also factor in the number of
neurons involved and the distance the
signal has to travel
let's see what this looks like in a
simple pathway your knee jerk
a strike to your patellar tendon
triggers an electrical impulse
that travels up a sensory neuron to your
spine
there the signal branches and for the
sake of simplicity we'll consider the
segment that jumps into a motor neuron
to journey back down your leg
the total length of the neuron in that
pathway is about one meter
in someone who is five foot five inches
and on average
it takes 15 to 30 milliseconds from
strike
to kick speed is distance divided by
time so this signal travels somewhere
between
120 to 240 kilometers per hour
the initial action potential accounts
for one to five milliseconds
and synaptic transmissions only take 0.1
to 0.5 milliseconds
so the bulk of that time is spent within
the axons
this is consistent with research
findings that the average individual
neuron sends signals at around 180
kilometers per hour
but speeds can be boosted with
myelination and increased axon diameter
myelin is a fatty sheath that insulates
an axon preventing electrical currents
from leaking out
meanwhile axons with larger diameters
offer
less internal resistance these
compounded
factors can raise the speed of an action
potential as high as
432 kilometers per hour
there's plenty of variation some people
think faster than others and your own
speed of thought changes throughout your
lifetime
in particular as you reach old age the
myelin sheath covering your axons wears
down
and other neuronal structures degrade
back to the dastardly experiment arrows
shot from recurve bows
fly on average around 240 kilometers per
hour
which means that given a sufficiently
long myelinated or large diameter neuron
your thoughts could actually win the
race but
there's a wrinkle the arrow and your
thought don't leave the gate at the same
time
first the arrow fires then once you
perceive it
your signal can start down its path
processing images or music
participating in inner speech and
recalling memories all require
complicated neural pathways
that are nowhere close to the linearity
of the knee-jerk reflex
the speed at which these thoughts occur
is mostly consistent
with variations based on myelination and
axon diameter
but the duration of a thought will vary
significantly
depending on its roots pit stops and
destination
in this case when you perceive a
threatening stimulus
you'll invoke a fierce startle response
similar to the knee-jerk response
a startle can be involuntary and quite
fast
if the string twangs loud enough you
might react in less than 65 milliseconds
more likely though your start or
reaction will be based on sight
our eyes can process an image as quickly
as 13 milliseconds
the computation of what you're seeing
and determining the danger it poses
can take as long as 180 to 200
milliseconds
in that time the arrow will have gained
a head start of about 13 meters
the target is far enough away that
you've got
just enough of a chance to catch up if
you can quickly
and quite literally think your way out
[Music]
how might we observe the speed of
thought in real life without
cutting open someone's head one approach
is growing tiny little
pencil eraser-sized mini-brains learn
more about these fascinating blobs
with this video or learn how scientists
use electricity
traces and magnetic fields to see inside
your head